Einstein said I never think about the
future it comes soon enough and he was
right of course so today I'm here to ask
you to think of how the future is
happening now over the past 200 years
the world has experienced two major
waves of innovation first the Industrial
Revolution brought us machines and
factories railways electricity air
travel and our lives have never been the
same
then the internet revolution brought us
computing power data networks
unprecedented access to information and
communication and our lives have never
been the same now we are experiencing
another metamorphic change the
industrial Internet
it brings together intelligent machines
advanced analytics and the creativity of
people at work it's the marriage of
minds and machines
our lives will never be the same in my
current role I see up close how
technology is beginning to transform
industrial sectors that play a huge role
in our economy in our lives
energy aviation transportation
healthcare foreign economies this is
highly unusual and it's extremely
exciting because this is a
transformation as powerful as the
Industrial Revolution and more and
before the Industrial Revolution there
was no economic growth to speak of so
what is this industrial internet
Industrial machines are being equipped
with a growing number of electronic
sensors that allow them to see here feel
a lot more than ever before generating
prodigious amounts of data increasingly
sophisticated analytics then sift
through the data providing insights that
allow us to operate the machines in
entirely new ways a lot more efficiently
and not just individual machines but
fleets of locomotives airplanes entire
system
like power grids hospitals it is asset
optimization and system optimization of
course electronic sensors have been
around for some time but something has
changed a sharp decline in the cost of
sensors and thanks to advances in cloud
computing a rapid decrease in the cost
of storing and processing data so we are
moving to a world where the machines we
work with are not just intelligent they
are brilliant they are self-aware they
are predictive reactive and social it's
jet engines locomotives gas turbines
medical devices communicating seamlessly
with each other and with us it's a world
where information itself becomes
intelligent and comes to us
automatically when we need it without
having to look for it
we are beginning to deploy throughout
the industrial system embedded
virtualization multi-core processor
technology advanced the cloud-based
communications a new software-defined
machine infrastructure which allows
machine functionality to become
virtualized in software decoupling
machine software from hardware and
allowing us to remotely and
automatically monitor manage in upgrade
industrial assets why does any of this
matter at all well first of all it's
already allowing us to shift towards a
preventive condition based maintenance
which means fixing machines just before
they break without wasting time
servicing them on a fixed schedule and
this in turn it's pushing us towards
zero unplanned downtime which means
there will be no more power outages no
more flight delays so let me give you a
few examples of how these brilliant
machines work and some of the examples
may seem trivial some are clearly more
profound but all of them are going to
have a very powerful impact let's start
with aviation today 10% of all flights
cancellations and delays
due to unscheduled maintenance events
something was wrong and expectedly these
results in 8 billion dollars in costs
for the airline industry globally every
year not to mention the impact on all of
us stress inconvenience missed meetings
as we sit helplessly in an airport
terminal so how can the industrial
internet help here we developed a
preventive maintenance system which can
be installed on any aircraft it's self
learning and able to predict issues that
a human operator would miss the aircraft
while in flight will communicate with
technicians on the ground by the time it
lands they will already know if anything
needs to be serviced just in the u.s.
his system like this can prevent over
60,000 delays and cancellations every
year helping 7 million passengers get to
the destinations on time
or take healthcare today nurses spend an
average of 21 minutes per shift looking
for medical equipment
it seems trivial but it's less time
spent caring for patients st. Luke's
Medical Center in Houston Texas which
has deployed industrial internet
technology to electronically monitor and
connect patients staff and medical
equipment has reduced bad turnaround
times by nearly 1 hour if you need
surgery
one hour matters and means more patients
can be treated more lives can be saved
another Medical Center in Washington
state is piloting an application that
allows medical images from CT scanners
and MRIs to be analyzed in the cloud
developing better analytics at a lower
cost imagine a patient who has suffered
a severe trauma and it's the attention
of several specialists a neurologist a
cardiologist an orthopedic surgeon if
all of them can have instantaneous and
simultaneous access to scans and images
as they are taken they will be able to
deliver better healthcare faster
so all these translates into better
health outcomes but you can also deliver
substantial economic benefit
just a 1% reduction in existing in
efficiencies could yield savings of over
sixty billion dollars to the healthcare
industry worldwide and that is just a
drop in the sea compared to what we need
to do to make health care affordable on
a sustainable basis similar advances are
happening in energy including renewable
energy wind farms equipped with new
remote monitoring and diagnostics that
allow wind turbines to talk to each
other and adjust the picture of their
blades in a coordinated way depending on
how the wind is blowing can now produce
electricity at a cost of less than five
cents per kilowatt hour 10 years ago
that cost was 30 cents six times as much
the list goes on and it will grow fast
because industrial data are now growing
exponentially by 2020 they will account
for over 50% of all digital information
that this is not just about data so let
me switch gears and tell you how this is
impacting already the jobs we do every
day because this new wave of innovation
is bringing about new tools and
applications that will allow us to
collaborate in a smarter and faster way
making our jobs not just more efficient
but more rewarding imagine a field
engineer arriving at the wind farm with
a handheld device telling her which
turbines need servicing she already has
all the spare parts because the problems
were diagnosed in advance and if she
faces in an expected issue the same
handheld device will allow her to
communicate with colleagues at the
service center let them see what she
sees transmit data that they can run
through diagnostics and they can stream
videos that will guide her step-by-step
through whatever complex procedure is
needed to get the machines back up and
running and their interaction gets
documented and stored in a searchable
database let's stop and think about this
for a minute because this is a very
important point this new wave of
innovation is fundamentally changing the
way we work I know that many of you will
be concerned about the impact that
innovation might have on jobs
unemployment is already high and there
is always a fear that innovation will
destroy jobs an innovation is dis wrap
but let me stress two things here first
we've already lived through
mechanization of Agriculture automation
of Industry and employment has gone out
because innovation is fundamentally
about growth it makes products more
affordable it creates new demand new
jobs second there is a concern that in
the future that will only be room for
engineers data scientists and other
highly specialized workers and believe
me as an economist I'm also scared but
think about it just as a child can
easily figure out how to operate an iPad
so a new generation of mobile and
intuitive industrial applications will
make life easier for workers of all
skill levels the water of the future
will be more like Iron Man
than the Charlie Chaplin of modern times
and to be sure new high-skilled jobs
will be created
mechanical digital engineers who
understand both the machines and the
data managers who understand their
industry and the analytics and can
reorganize the business to take full
advantage of the technology but now
let's take a step back let's look at the
big picture there are people who argue
that today's innovation is all about
social media silly games with nowhere
near the transformational power of the
Industrial Revolution they say that all
the growth and hansung innovations are
behind us and every time I hear this I
can't help thinking that even back in
the Stone Age there must have been a
group of cavemen sitting around the fire
one day looking very grumpy and looking
disapprovingly at another group of
caveman rolling a stone wheel up and
down a hill and saying to each other
yeah this will thing cool toy sure but
compared to fire it will have no impact
the big discoveries are all behind us
this technological revolution is as
inspiring and transformational as
anything we have ever seen human
creativity and innovation have always
propelled us forward they've created
jobs they raise living standards they've
made our lives healthier and more
rewarding and the new wave of innovation
which is beginning to sweep through
industry is no different in the US alone
the industrial internet could
raise average incomes by 25 to 40
percent over the next 15 years boosting
growth rates we haven't seen in a long
time and adding between 10 and 15
trillion dollars to global GDP there is
the size of the entire US economy today
but this is not a foregone conclusion we
are just at the beginning of this
transformation there will be barriers to
break obstacles to overcome we will need
to invest in the new technologies we
will need to adapt organizations and
managerial practices we will need a
robust cybersecurity approach that
protects the sensitive information
intellectual property and safeguards
critical infrastructure from cyber
attacks in the education system will
need to evolve to ensure students are
equipped with the right skills it is not
going to be easy but it is going to be
worth it the economic challenges facing
us are hard but when I walk the factory
floor and I see how humans and brilliant
machines are becoming interconnected and
I see the difference this makes in a
hospital in an airport in a power
generation plant I'm not just optimistic
I am enthusiastic this new technological
revolution is upon us so think about the
future it will be here soon enough thank
you
[Applause]